you've got about 10 to 20 seconds before
you're live
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
our planning committee my name is
councillor peter richards and i will be
chairing the meeting
uh if we cover some housekeeping first
of all uh members you'll have all been
sent um the council etiquette for
virtual meetings in advance of this
meeting but if i could just refresh your
memory with a few key points
if you could please ensure your device
is fully charged or is charging we don't
want to drop you out
halfway through the meeting and please
remember to mute your microphones
after you've finished speaking and if
you could obviously unmute them so that
we can hear you when you are speaking
that would also be helpful
um indicate if you would in the chat bar
if you wish to speak
i will keep a record of that and keep
that open so i will know if you need to
speak and i'll call you in
at the appropriate time uh when you are
asked to arrest the committee again if
you could turn your microphone back on
again
and just announce your name before you
start speaking so we know who it is
um if for any reason you encounter any
i.t problems causing you to drop out if
you could make every effort to get back
in as soon as you possibly can that
would be great
you will have been deemed to have left
the meeting at the point at which you
lose connection so the sooner you can
get in uh back in the better
um if for any reason you're unable to
rejoin there are two numbers that will
pop up in your chat in just a moment
for committee services and for it if you
give them a call they will help you
get back in again um please do also
remember that we are being
recorded and broadcast live and so we
are in full view of members of the
public and will be
on our youtube channel for uh many years
to come um for people that have
registered to speak some members of the
public that have registered to speak
um as i say we are being recorded we are
being broadcast live
um by registering to speak you are
consenting to be
recorded and for the possible use of
both the video and sound recordings for
webcasting and or
training in uh future weeks or months
okay um let me start now by introducing
our
offices um we have uh offices from
democrat services legal and
planning so if i start with uh
democratic services we have liz jaworska
who is helping
run the committee tonight uh from legal
we have mina mack our solicitor
and from planning we have eddie wrench
who is one of our planners joe brooke
also one of our planners and david
jeffery who is our senior planner
and uh planning manager for tonight's
david if you've got a little statement i
think you'd like to make please
thank you chair um i say my name is
david jeffrey
my role is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
fabulous thank you very much david
okay let's get into the meeting proper
then so first of all do we have any
apologies for absence
yes we do chairman um we've got uh
colleges we've got apologies from
councillor adam and curtis
okay lovely thank you very much um if we
have any disclosures of interests guys
if you could please pop in the meeting
chat if you have any disclosures of
interest
i will start uh by saying that the final
application this evening which is twenty
zero one six hundred
ful sambar farm in uh hampton lucy that
is part of my ward
uh although i have um come with an open
mind and will
maintain my position on the committee
and be part of the debate and
vote councillor parry has
a disclosure cancer parry thank you and
good evening chair
um i'd also just like to highlight i'm
the county councillor
for the final application on the agenda
this evening
which is sanbom farm but i've come to
the committee
with an open mind and will still remain
seated
on the committee and join the debate and
vote
thank you fabulous thank you councillor
parry and councilman mills
thanks mr chairman yes um on the first
application hornbeam house
um uh i have had
um um conversations with
uh roger thatcher um about hornbeam
house
uh which crept up in other matters
um also i was involved with hornbeam
house when uh because being a joining
uh ward member
in place of nigel rock but i have an
open mind on this mr chairman
and i will be staying on the committee
thank you
fabulous thank you councillor mills and
finally councillor crump
thank you mr chairman i'm acting
uh county councillor for uh
friendly compton um again coming to the
meeting with an open mind
and we'll be staying on the committee
for this item
thank you fantastic thank you very much
okay let's go to our minutes then so
this is to confirm
and i will sign after this meeting uh
minutes from our committee on the 19th
of august
9th of september and 16th of september
that was planning committee
a we also have uh planning committee b
from the 12th of august 26th
august and 16th of september and then
another planning committee for 16th of
september
they're all in your pack is everyone
happy with them if i could have a thumbs
up
i can see look yeah that's a unanimous
thumbs up fabulous i will sign them
next time i'm in the office okay in that
case we're on to
our first proper item for this evening
which is item number 1903267
fuel that is hornbeam house in fenney
compton our presenting officer is eddie
wrench eddie
over to you whenever you are ready
please begin
thank you chair should be able to hear
me now sorry um
the application is for a green fence
along the northern garden boundary
involving recessing an existing fencing
panels
as can be seen here the application site
is located within
fenney compton as denoted here by the
black dot
uh the site is within the conservation
area which is shown by the
pink outline here although it isn't a
listed building in itself
this slide shows the site area
for the site the wall that we're talking
about here is the northern
boundary of the property which fronts
onto brook street to the north
there's also some uh indic
indicative plans showing the how the uh
proposed green wall would sit in front
of the
existing fence which would be slightly
recessed
uh which can be seen here
uh here is the proposed uh and existing
elevations
uh the one on the top of the screen
is the existing elevation which is for
the unauthorized close boarded fence in
the location
uh with the proposed on the
bottom of the page showing the green
wall uh
inserted over the top of that the wall
uh currently exists about two and a half
meters high which would be
equaled by the green wall
uh finally uh here is a picture of the
fence as it is today so the green fence
would sit in front of that and this is
from brook street
uh updates are one correction uh
spelling mistake within the report uh
inc
councillor rock's submission
but chair the officers officer's
recommendation is to refuse for the
reasons on page 79 of the report
thank you eddie thank you very much for
that
uh we will go straight to our first
speakers who are councillors
roddy weir and councillor john dutton
from fenney compton
parish council um if you guys could
please press
star and six on your keypads you will be
able to unmute yourselves
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
straight away starts
can you hear me okay i certainly can
yeah welcome
and do we have thank you council dutton
with you as well or are you
is it just yourself speaking yes
i'm getting a couple of people speaking
at the moment so what i propose that we
do
is if we start uh with cancer where um
and i presume you're going to be uh
having about a minute and a half we can
give you a warning or as soon as you're
done if
uh counselor dutton wants to take over
uh and start speaking
that would be great we'll give you a
thirty second warning before the three
minutes is
up um so yourself to speak tonight so
okay perfect in that case we will let
you crack on for your full time
and when there's 30 seconds to go for
three minutes we will give you a
30 second warning over to you when
you're ready
thank you just one quick question can
you see the slide pack i've
provided earlier we can okay right i'll
start now then thank you
uh the parish council are supportive of
the green wall as it would last you
restore the property to its prior
condition
with its natural hedge which is shown on
slide two and googler
as such we believe it would fit with the
historic layout of the street
um the parish council are all
in the current structure we believe
sympathetic to the current street which
is far more diverse in its nature than
the planning report suggests
but other materials being used within
and on the property's boundaries
as well as painted and present rendered
and painted resonance is clearly visible
from hornbeam house
this is showing on slides three and four
to the right of the house there is an
existing
wooden fence as single construction mask
left to the boundary wall and aspect to
largely red brick
within direct view of the property in
either direction are rendered facade
with white and violet paint
and so that's shown on the two slides
the fence is in similar color to the
house existing
adjacent stone wall and fans meaning it
forms past the continuous pound of
natural changing colours
than the immediate area
there is a wide variety of diversity of
materials used for boundaries within the
conservation area and wider connotation
construction is not after keeping with
other fences and it's similar to one
recently granted planning commission at
the ridgeway
just outside the conservation area with
similar fences being highlighted the
blue board are shown on slide five
which just shows a diversity of
properties in the village
and finally there's been overwhelming
support for our parishioners to keeping
the existing structure
which i believe is in the planning
notice comments
that's it from me thank you marvelous
thank you very much if you could just
hold on the line for a second while we
see if members have any questions for
you so members if you could indicate
please in the chat
if you would like to ask a question of
our counselors
i'm not seeing much activity as a few
shaking heads
on that basis i'm going to assume there
are no questions um so
uh counselor aware counselor many thanks
and if you would like to
continue watching the live broadcast
through our website
and that would be terrific
thank you very much thank you
we will move now in that case to our
next speakers who are mr and mrs jones
the applicants again if they could press
star and six to unmute themselves
and let me know when hopefully we can
hear them
good evening good evening that's mr
jones uh
yes rodney jones says my wife won't be
speaking it's just myself
okay lovely um you have three minutes we
will give you a 30-second warning
whenever you're ready to start speaking
please do go ahead
thank you very much for the opportunity
dear committee members
having seen what council iraq is going
to say we do not want to overlap or
repeat things
to be brief we had planning permission
to build a hortonstone wall
when construction started electricity
mains telephone cables and water mains
were discovered
our best alternative to the wall is the
fence of similar height
roger thatcher contacted us and advised
that the fence did not have permission
and we should apply for retrospective
planning permission
which he intimated would be a formality
this was refused and on appeal refused
again
we were then dumbfounded that we
enforcement notice
may be issued the officer said he would
let us know how this progressed yet the
very same day the notice was issued and
at the same time a very hostile phone
call from roger thatcher left my wife in
tears
this latest application started out as a
horton stone screening to make the fence
and street scene match our neighbour's
wall and fence
we have unwavering support from our
direct neighbours and the village
35 people wrote directly to eat planning
148 letters from villagers in full
support and over 550 signatures on
petitions
heritage consultants indicated full
support to the proposed screening
these now seem to have all been
overlooked we were strongly advised by
the planning officer to withdraw the
application
as it stood no chance of success we were
also advised that changing the screening
to a green wall
would be looked at more favorably we
signed an affidavit
undertaking evergreen foliage covering
the fence this was rejected
the planning officer suggested mobiline
living iv screening and sent a link to
their website for us
and showing slide 1 we considered this a
good idea as a
ready-grown mature ivy however this is
now being put forward for refusal
we keep asking ourselves what are we
supposed to do
it seems however much we try there will
be a reason for rejection
warwick highways agency does not have
any issues with this application
the verge has been planted and
maintained by previous residents and
us for over 40 years reliably informed
by a neighbor who lives on the street
her whole life
over 60 years we ask ourselves how the
fence will remain a prominent feature
when it will be covered in mature plants
as our photograph shows later is already
well covered by established planting
we fear our planning consultant and our
lawyer seems to have annoyed
the planning department in some way we
are absolutely terrified that our dog
and puppy could be killed on the road if
the fence is removed we live in the
centre of any compton in a 20 mile per
hour speed limit area
the traffic coming from north end road
rarely adheres to this speed limit
my wife and i thoroughly enjoy living in
fenney compton for over five years now
and no time have we received any
negative comments about the fence only
compliments of our roses
and how well maintained the verge is on
three separate occasions we've been
asked where we got the fence because
they love it
to sum up it seems whatever we say or
suggest the planning officer
is not going to agree to any form of
permission in slide two
please look at this photograph taken one
month ago and tell me this is an eye
sore and out of character for a village
this planning process has caused us many
sleepless nights and untold stress
which we never envisaged would happen
when we started out with our first
application
thank you so much for your time and we
hope you will grant our application
mr jones i think you've got that
absolutely spot on time-wise so thank
you very much
um if you could just hold on the line
for a second i'm going to ask my
members if they have any questions i've
already had councillor crump indicate
he'd like to speak so councillor crump
if you'd like to fire away
thank you hello mr jones um funnily
enough i was in
favor compton went past brook street
today looking at
flooding with councillor payne um right
so yeah i'll walk right past it again
today so i do have one
did you say that you and the previous
occupants had and maintained the verge
for
40 years i just i didn't quite catch
we've lived here five
and a neighbor has lived on the street
her whole life and she's 60 plus
and she says it's always been maintained
by whoever's lived here
the previous residents i believe were
here about 20 years
and they had the hormone hedge and roses
at the other side of the hornbeam hedge
as well
yeah very no that's great let's just
clarify that point for me so
um thank you very much okay thank you oh
thank you councillor crump um
counselors any other questions from mr
jones
i'm not seeing much activity at the
moment so i'm going to assume that's a
no
mr jones thank you very much for your
input this evening again if you if you
you're welcome to stay and listen on
your phone but if you could press star 6
to mute yourself that would be great
otherwise
and probably easier for you is to watch
the live stream through um
our website but thank you very much
indeed i will do that
thank you marvelous thank you okay
we will move to our next and final
speaker on this item which is councillor
rock
council rock welcome it's good to see
you
you know the drill you've got five
minutes when you're ready please start
we'll give you 30 second warning over to
you
so thank you very much mr chairman i'll
see eddie's
ready with the slides so thank you very
much so we've got slide one
this is a planning application exactly
in accordance with our green wall
spd part e written for the purpose
personally i can't see the level of harm
of the current fences that bad
but neither can the 500 residents that
signed the petition in
possession of the council however here
we are trying to approve its appearance
further
early in 2016 the applicants wanted to
improve their privacy and security
and the street scene by replacing the
rather scruffy hedge with a wall
digging for footings conflicted with a
variety of services
which subsequently have found to include
the municipal water supply
foundations for the boundary wall were
thus infeasible
the applicants thought a high quality
fence of the same height and location as
the wall would be okay
not so after finding this out by
enforcement action
they properly applied for permission for
the fence
this was refused and dismissed on appeal
on the grounds that the appearance of
defense
caused less than substantial harm
to the street scene slide two please
very compton uh water plus
neither the planners and the inspector
were presented the evidence of the
potential disruption to the municipal
water supply by the construction of a
wall
thus a tilted planning balance test was
not applied
slide 3 please finding the council had a
policy in the form of
spde and had approved in may 2016
green walls in a very similar situation
in kington
the applicants put in this proposal
before you now
the applicants provided a brochure from
a specific system
mobiline and photographs of a single
panel in situ
could have slide 4 please officers
decided that this was still in
sufficient detail
apparently wanting installation drawings
the stated intent is for approved
contractors to install the sections as
required in line with
mobile lane's product requirements we
should look at the appearance outcome
which is shown in the drawings and
illustrations
the approved application at kineton 15
stroke 3308 full
supplied less detailed degree more than
this one does
the applicant there only supplied a
photograph without a drawing
in my view the applicants here have
sufficiently described the planning
aspects of the proposal the report
further argues that the proposal may
overlap highways maintain land
could have slide four please sorry
don't you got it you yep uh
um clearly the the fence and green wall
will be much thinner than the original
hedge
the owners of the property been
maintaining this strip as we've heard
for many years because it fell within
the spread of the hedge
geographic evidence to this effect going
by 13 years so to my understanding the
applicants could claim legal ownership
however i don't think it's for the
planning authority to indulge in a
debate
on illegal ownership of an historic
boundary from the 17th century
suggesting it can be determined within a
few inches next slide please
a living green wall aligns with the new
climate change
spd part v page 8 of that spd
illustrates a green wall finish applied
to a timber wall of a home garden office
slide 7 please the specific
spd e9 for green walls was used as a
guide for this application
and the design exactly conforms with
that
additionally it would be perverse to
refuse something that rapid
replicates the appearance of the hedge
it replaces
refusal would be inconsistent with other
green walls that have been granted
permission and indeed encouraged by
policy next slide please
the application therefore enhances the
street scene
responds to the climate emergency and
conforms with
cs7b cs 9.2
cs 9.5 cs12
spd part e9 spd part v5.3
i ask that you grant the application
thank you colleagues
council rock thank you very much um we
have a couple of people indicating to
speak
so if we can start with councillor mills
please
thanks mr chairman um nigel sorry
on your presentation were you also
mentioning
um services you know as in
electricity water or whatever did you
did you mentioned that
uh yes councillor mills are um
the the services obviously i speak from
indirect knowledge here this is
lead from the uh the applicants but um
there are services that run along the
line of the
verge or where the foundations would be
when they're trying to erect the wall
which would be quite a tall wall
and subsequently we've discovered that
the services in question
are the public water supply if any
compton has the oldest
water company
we do appear to be experiencing some
minor technical difficulties with
councillor rock though
you're frozen he has frozen he did that
a couple of times earlier on so i wonder
if he's gonna come back to us or not
there you are we missed all that nigel
councillor rock are you
um you you glitch somewhat there i don't
know if you're
still able to hear us and speak properly
if you could just
i can hear you shall i say that again if
you wouldn't mind please that would be
helpful
did you miss everything
right okay but as far as the services
are concerned running along the line of
the
uh projected uh wall the
applicants intended to build i speak
from indirect knowledge
this is only what i've been told however
since this long-running saga has
developed i have discovered that the
phenical water companies
supply pipes run along this line and
they have supplied me with
a plan of that the fenney compton water
company
is the oldest water private water
company in the country
and supplies a number of properties
along that line and they have written to
me asking
that their ancient water supply is not
disturbed by it
and there would be a public dis benefit
in that supply should that be disturbed
okay lovely council mills if you're
gonna follow up to that yeah um
so when they
it was there was a war there originally
nigel
no no there was a hornbeam hedge just
though just the hornbeam hedge so
the the roots didn't affect these pipes
or at all
no it would not again i speak from
indirect knowledge
okay all right thanks very much thank
you
thank you both uh councillor crump have
you indicated that you wanted to speak
or have a question here
you are muted at the moment that's
that's a pretty that's a legacy one
okay i wasn't sure lovely thank you um
members
have we got any other questions for
councillor rock lots of shaken heads
okay marvelous casa rock thank you once
again for joining us this evening if you
want to uh continue to watch our online
you're most welcome to do so
thank you we will move now into uh
points of clarification for
our offices so members if you have any
questions
for our officer please indicate in the
chats now
while you're deciding what you want to
ask him i will ask eddie
does this site um have permissive
development rights
and under the permitted development
right would they not be able to build or
install a
a fence of a certain height
thanks chair um as far as i know yep
it does have committed development
rights uh being adjacent to the highway
i think it could only be sorry i'm just
getting open my pd rights
but i think it would only be up to a
meter in height so
probably not from what their point of
view in terms of privacy and
um security reasons it probably wouldn't
do that but they could put a type of one
to a certain extent
so that would be correct so he isn't
listed so obviously isn't restricted by
that part
so it's but it's a maximum of a meter by
virtue of the fact that it's next to the
road
yeah it's adjacent to the highway so
it's restricted by that fact
i understood okay uh counselor dixon you
have a question
thank you chairman eddie um councilor
rock uh
was quite uh vocal in mentioning the
fact that
these green walls are part of our are
encouraged by policy
uh is that or do does
that equally uh uh
react with conservation areas and
implementation in the
conservation areas as well as in other
non-conservation areas thank you
i mean in terms of uh as councillor rock
said
in terms of climate change and
supporting green
features and green infrastructure
it does form part of that and obviously
quite often in terms of hedges or green
walls they wouldn't require
planning commissioning of themselves
it's only because this is a structural
as a structural framework to it where it
requires planning permission
but it would be supported in a
roundabout way in terms of
yeah those climate change um
you know target i mean the majority of
green walls that
in my experience tend to be more of a
urban design
city center feature type wall or
sometimes you get it on large blocks of
flats but as i think has been shown it
has become more common within
developments in terms of a
softer feature than a traditional brick
wall or close boarded fence
um so i mean it doesn't
depend on each individual site in its
own right obviously
i think i've had a look on the site
today and they do do hornbeam versions
as well
which obviously would be the most
similar to what was previously happening
in the in in the past which was removed
so i don't think in principle we have a
a massive objection in terms of the
green wall i think
reading lindsay's report it's mainly to
do with some of the details and how it's
been set out and
some clarifications on their points and
i think one of the issues is obviously
the retention of the
existing close boarded fence
and i think it's been alluded to before
as well about how we could maintain that
and
not lead to any loss in that green wall
where the fence would
override it but um i mean it is a
case-by-case thing but i would say
overall we are supportive in terms of
green walls that's right
yeah i don't know if david wants to add
anything to that yeah i think i would
just add something to that eddie i i
think councillor rock referred
specifically to our
development requirements spd and he's
correct that there is
uh strong support there for green walls
in terms of
um the benefits which they bring
however is acknowledged i think in in
the section
uh referred to that they may not be
appropriate in all circumstances
and um there are different options
available uh for different locations and
we have to
uh remember that the spd doesn't provide
us with policy it provides us with
guidance on
um how our policy should be interpreted
so the the starting point for decision
making here is of course strategies
policies
um it's guided by the spd so policy cs9
um and our policy in relation to
conservation areas
and heritage assets so we need to um you
know consider
those comments with balance um against
the policies
uh thank you thank you very much david
thank you
uh eddie thanks thank you to all of you
um
okay so uh councillor crump has
indicated he has a question cancel the
crime
yeah i think just um this is not meant
to be facetious or
or jovial um just a question of interest
you indicated that a three uh one meter
fence would probably be
um acceptable but obviously that
probably won't accept all to the
applicant
how do trellises on top of these fences
are they consider this part
or can they um for example if somebody
put a three-foot trellis on top of that
fence would that still be counted as a
fence
or is it a separate item again i'm just
just yeah
no no that would be included in the
whole of the fence so yeah
you couldn't get around it as it were in
that sense it is
all to consider to be one structure so
yeah if you start adding elements to it
it all becomes part of said fence really
so yeah
okay where to try
council parry
thank you chair um i was just my
question to the officers were that
if we were minded to go
down the route of grant um could we
condition
the style of the garden wall to reflect
a hornbeam
hedge um type
yeah i certainly think um going through
the details i think if you were minded
to approve then we would be looking for
further details here of the species mix
and um some more details just about that
how it's going to be constructed or
attached to the fence as well so
yeah my recommendation if you went down
that line would be for
details to further details to be
submitted in terms of
those aspects certainly
okay thank you and casa jennings please
thank you thank you chairman uh
councillor paris just asked one of the
questions which i just wanted to ask
so that's been answered thank you very
much news my other little bit
it was so if this wasn't a wooden fence
which the
green wall was attached to for instance
it was a wire mesh like a sheet mesh
or something then that probably would be
acceptable would it
i mean i think by just having obviously
the fence post with a wire mesh the
there's more incentive to obviously
maintain that hedge
because that provides literally the
demarcation between their land and the
highway
so there's more likelihood of um it's
supporting it over a longer term
also as the the green wall has proposed
is obviously to the north
of the existing fence as well so there'd
obviously be benefits in terms of growth
from
you know additional sun and those
elements as well
um so i think the the main objection
that
i can understand to come forward is that
yeah the the where the details have come
and also not having that uh existing
close boarded fence
would be part of that uh element as well
so yeah if that
was removed i think it would uh overcome
certain amount of concerns that we have
i think those those details are not
before members i think that
what members should attempt to focus on
if they can
is the details that are before us um in
terms of this proposal
um alternative proposals may come
forward in time however
uh details before us are for
consideration tonight
thank you very much thank you thank you
all um
just on that fence the the existing
fencing obviously the description
development is
it does say involving recessing of the
existing fence panels um given that is
an integral part of the
application there's no way we could say
have a condition in the same removal of
the existing
if we were to go if we were money to go
down the ground
i think that's not the proposal that's
been made yeah i feel like that was my
gut feel that we're pushing towards
changing the material nature of the
planning application
okay um eddie do you know how tall the
original hornbeam uh hedging was
well i don't unfortunately i think it
was fairly tall
i would imagine i think going from
councillor rock's pictures and
some of the other details it looked
quite substantial
more than two and a half meters i would
uh i would hazard against that but
possibly when uncut yeah i just wrote
okay councilor mills do you have a
question
yes thanks richard uh eddie could you
put
a photograph up a game for me please of
the fence
uh it's got some roses growing up it
uh the applicant's picture oh was it
yeah
yeah i think that's the one you're
referring to there's
is it this one no you can't see
yes that's it thank you uh
yeah that's okay that's that's one this
thank you that's all i need to see thank
you very much
no problem thank you
okay good so uh we have no one else
indicating they have any points of
clarification so let's move
into our debate who would like to start
councillor parry
right um just unmuted myself
um i think there needs to be an element
of common sense here
and i think we need to try and find um
a resolution for for these for the
applicants who um
i can quite appreciate have been under a
huge amount of stress
um and concern and as i say i think
you know there's an opportunity here for
for a compromise
and and i would like um to propose
that we go with grant um
i would like to see a condition if it's
possible that
um on discussion with
with the applicants um i would favor
um a replication of the the horn
the hornbeam type of hedge but i really
think
you know we need to find a resolution
here um
and so therefore i i would be happy to
propose that we go with grant
on the basis that i think the harm
to the character of the street scene um
is certainly way less than substantial
um and and that would be my proposal
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor parry
uh we have three other members
registered to speak so councillor eden
first of all
thank you chair uh i think in many
respects i agree with councillor paris
uh we need a sensible uh happy medium
here and i do think that this
application probably offers that
and i would uh like to second her
proposal actually especially with the
conditions around the
uh the hedge type and the like so yeah
that'll do for me
lovely thank you councillor adam and
councilman mills
thanks mr chairman yes as you know
always going to look at these
applications and
just looking at that photograph again i
mean personally i can't see what's
what is wrong with that um fence but um
i'll go along with um anne's
proposal on this mr chairman i i would
go for grant
um i i know that our
uh enforcement officers are extremely
uh professional in their approach to
this um i'm sure um
if i could if i might if i may say so
that um
roger thatcher absolutely no intention
of upsetting anybody who's far from that
sort of professional person so um thank
you very much mr chairman thank you
thank you councillor mills councillor
kendall thank you chairman
uh i think most of it's been said
actually i agree completely what council
mills has just said i
i can't really see a major issue with
the with the fences it is
um we need to come up with a resolution
we need to come through this uh
the committee is here to make decisions
when when it's a finally balanced one i
think this is finally about so i think
on this occasion i would go with
councillor paris proposition thank you
marvelous thank you very much um i can
see cancer crump has said happy to
second uh the proposal although it has
already been done
council trump do you want to say
anything at this point you can shake
your head if it's a no
no no it's all been said marvelous thank
you
okay um brilliant thank you uh members
um no one else has
said they wanted to speak so i'll just
uh dive in right now um
now i don't necessarily disagree with
what's just been said but i would just
remind members that we
have had uh on i believe on two
occasions now appeals
that have indicated that the fence would
be inappropriate in its position so just
bear that in mind
um i'm going to seek guidance from uh
david jeffery about that um specifically
do we need to give a clear concise
reason as to why we disagree with
the planning inspectors um responses
or are you satisfied that the reasons
that have been given
are sufficient um
i think i would like
you've started to break up never say
slightly
you were glitching a little bit earlier
on as well would you mind turning your
if you turn your video feed off we might
be able to hear you a bit more clearly
as much as we'd like to learn thank you
suggestions
yeah as i say i think just adding a
little nuance to what members were
were talking about in terms of um our
core strategy policy cs8
which seeks to preserve the historic
environment
um the reason the previous appeal failed
in my view was that because the
inspector considered that there was less
than substantial harm
to a designated heritage asset for
such harm to be overcome it's necessary
for there to be public benefit
on the basis of what i've heard members
discuss it sounds as though members
consider that there is a public benefit
arising from
this proposal for a green screen in
front of the existing fence
um that in their view overcomes uh
the harm to the conservation area and
any other harm arising
so i think on that basis that's if if
members are willing to accept that as
uh the reason that would be sufficient
to to address the concern there
um i take the nods to
to mean that that's agreed um moving on
then
i think you're probably going to ask me
chair
whether there are any appropriate
conditions that we would seek to
impose on any resolution and
and whether councillor parry would like
to agree those for her
um proposal in that respect i'd
recommend a condition relating to a time
limit for implementation
of this development
we've been recommending three years and
six months
over six months over and above the usual
because of the current covid
situation um uh
development in accordance with the plans
submitted
um notwithstanding a condition saying
notwithstanding those plans
full details of the green wall should be
provided in advance of construction so
that
officers can receive the technical
details of the
green wall to be provided and the last
one i've got
is a condition requiring details of the
planting
to be hornbeam and we would ordinarily
um
put clauses within that condition to
secure replacement planting should that
planting fail
um for a period of say five years uh
following the development um eddie were
there any further conditions that you
had
considered well it wasn't necessarily a
condition but i noticed
um obviously our standard condition is
the five years replacement but the
applicant has put forward uh
uu um to make as a covenant to
do it in perpetuity so i don't know
whether that's something mean i want to
pick up or something we want to pursue
or whether you're satisfied members are
satisfied with the five-year period for
replacement uh just picking up on that
if
um a eu has been a unilateral
undertaking has been proposed it's
certainly something members could
consider
um but if members are happy with the
five years um
alternatively that could be conditioned
um but you should have
give regard to the proposal of the
unilateral undertaking too
okay thank you all for that um i'm
entirely happy with the conditions that
you've laid out
um particularly the hornbeam one um i
believe that is exactly what cancer
parry had said so i
will seek her thumbs up in just a moment
um councillor perry in terms of the
um unilateral undertaking in perpetuity
versus five years
i can see you've indicated in the chat
that you're happy with the five year
replacement do you
just want to talk to that so that the
members of the public can see and here
yeah i'm i am happy with the five years
i think on
on certain things like this particularly
on property matters it's
it's far more sensible to keep things
fairly simple and straightforward
um particularly going forward if the
property in
future years changes hands i can see
just having a unilateral agreement
causing great problems between one
property solicitor and another
um so my view i would be quite happy
with the five years replacement
okay very good um i can
see that uh casa jennings has indicated
support for the five years council
kendall has done the same
um this was seconded uh by councillor
eden so
i must seek his confirmation that he's
happy with the five years council eden
jewish want to come in at this point and
say yes
yeah absolutely very happy with that
thanks
good thank you i did say say yes
assuming that you were going to say yes
you were of course entitled to saying no
if you disagreed with me
um so i think that i mean it's not
unanimous because i can see councillor
dixon has uh
has uh mentioned the uh you know
undertaking cancer dixon do you want to
say anything to
to that or are you um are you happy with
what's been said so far by everyone else
i can understand councillor parry
commenting about it the change of
property
change of owner etc uh in due course
obviously will change ownership
and i'm just wondering what would
actually be there if
a new owner said i don't really want
vegetation on the outside of this fence
and it was all filled up with uh with
roundup we would be back with a terrible
looking fence
so personally i would like to see the
undertaking
okay i i sort of tend to
er i'm inclined to agree with you
councillor dixon on that but also i'm
also
fairly relaxed about the five years as
well um mina you've indicated you'd like
to come in and speak would you like to
do that now
yeah that's right and just picking up on
the unilateral undertaking
uh just to clarify um that it would run
with the land so it would find successes
in title
and who take over ownership for the land
as well
sorry could you say that again sorry
just so i've got that clear in my mind
so the unilateral undertaking would bind
successes entitled to the land
so if ownership changes it would be
binding on the successors in title
okay i'm
in a slight quandary over this members
in that um
council dixon has made a very valid
point that if we don't have that in
perpetuity
uh um safeguard i guess on on this
uh green wall um notwithstanding
obviously the commitment that's being
made by the
the existing owner as and when we move
to a new owner we're back in the
position we could find ourselves back in
a position where
a fence that has been deemed
inappropriate by a planning inspector as
well as our own planning officers
suddenly becomes there uh by default
um that is assuming that whoever buys
the property or takes over the property
um doesn't want to have a hormone hedge
outside i'd find that bizarre given it's
called hornbeam house
but you never know um do you want
members do you want to have any further
debate on that or are you happy to just
move ahead with a proposal as has been
made with
five years i just want a quick thumbs up
i can see lots of nodding heads
okay let's let's move forward then in
that case on the proposal that has been
second to
proposed by councillor parry seconded by
councillor eden um
i will start uh
and say council richards slightly
reluctantly
four thank you chairman councillor
fleming
cashier flaring for councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crump
caster crump for councillor dixon
abstech councillor dixon abstain thank
you
councillor eden councillor for
councillor henshaw seraphin and sentra
seraphine for
councillor jennings councillor jennings
ball
councillor mills council mills four
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
thank you that's 94 chairman with one
abstention
marvelous thank you very much liz okay
in that case committee resolves then to
grant application 1903 267
f u l for the reasons and with the
conditions
set out just now um so
uh we will take just a very quick
uh break um for two minutes while we
call in the speakers for our next
item so please don't run off too far
remember this is still being streamed so
please put your microphones on
mute
okay members we do now have
our uh we do not have our uh speakers in
the meeting so we are set and ready to
go with our next
application so if we could have your
attention back on your screens that
would be appreciated
um the application is twenty zero zero
three four three full that is land at
camden road in
shipston on star uh our presenting
officer is once again
mr eddie wrench so eddie over to you
thank you chair uh the application is
for
65 affordable dwellings 35 social rent
and 30
intermediate plus associated access
parking landscape and associated
infrastructure
uh the site is located uh
on the western side of ships and on
sauer
estara an area which has been
significantly developed over the last
few years
the site here is denoted by the black
dot which is to the north of the camden
road
uh this is the proposed site layout of
the 65 dwellings
with the suds pond just located to
directly to the east
and they're currently being built out
taylor wimpy site to the north and west
as shown here
this is these are some of the proposed
street scenes within the development
which show the various different house
types
there will be a mixture of red bricks
with red and grey roof tiles
with key properties uh having chimneys
as well
there's a mix of two and a half story
mainly two story
and two bungalows as well within the
housing mix
these are some of the proposed uh
proposed and existing cross sections
through the site which runs from the
camden road on the left
up to the hills on the right and the top
is the existing
topography of the site where there is a
small
grouping of vegetation and a small pond
within the center that would make way
for the development
um on the bottom you can see that
uh it's very similar topography there
wouldn't be much cut and fill so
it would follow a similar line to the
adjacent taylor wimpy site in that
respect
uh here's one photo from the camden road
looking across the site
um the taylor wimpy development which is
occupied to some extent at the moment
but is currently being built out
uh can be viewed on the left hand side
and to the rear of the site
is also part of the taylor wimpy
development
to the far right of the development is
the more historic edge of the
town which has obviously been extended
now through the new development so this
site does lie within the built-up area
boundary
of the town this is looking down the
camden road with the crest nicholson
development across the road
which is again substantially completed
from that point of view as well
there is footways that go all the way
into town
which future occupiers would use as well
this is just another site looking
northwards towards the taylor wimpy site
uh again that is towards the trailer
would be site but this also
has in view the uh sud pond which is
proposed to be permanently wet which
will encourage certain bio diversity
improvements
which is significant given the loss of
some vegetation on the site
although the majority of the site is
currently scrub land as can be seen
and that's the end of the presentation
updates include a letter of support from
the development a
enabling officer giving their strong
support for the proposals
and there's also a client clarification
of one policy point as well within that
chairman the recommendation is to grant
subject to the section 106
and condition and contributions set out
on pages 45 and 46
of the agenda thank you eddie that's
brilliant thank you very much well done
um we will go straight to our first
speaker who i believe is councillor paul
tesh from
shipston town council uh councillor tash
are you there you may need to press
start
and sex to unmute yourself
hopefully we'll be able to hear you
shortly hello
hello is that uh counselor tesh yes it
is
yes hello the online
the online streaming seems to be about
two or three minutes behind the
um behind this so uh
that's that's right what's going on
there whether it's our dodgy internet in
ships that i don't know no it it's it's
it's perfectly normal but
it's obviously with the video being
processed and then being uploaded and
then streamed out
it uh there is an inevitable delay so um
i i would suggest you if you are
watching uh on
on a webcast elsewhere that that is
muted while you speak now because we
will probably get some feedback
um
perfect okay well you have three minutes
um
if you could stay on the line afterwards
for questions from members that would be
great
we will give you a 30-second warning
when your uh your time is nearly up
aside from that whenever you're ready
it's over to you
right thank you shifts and town council
has concerns regarding
the proposed details of the development
and objects on the following grounds
the inadequate number of bungalows for
rent as there is a shortage of bungalows
at affordable rents in ships and on
staff for both the elderly and
physically impaired
that's two that no open space is being
provided within the development as there
is a significant shortfall of public
open space within shipstand
the application does not conform with
the neighborhood plan policy
hsg7 encouraging custom and self-built
housing opportunities
policy stipulates that for developments
of more than 20
units the developer is encouraged to
provide at least
five percent of the plots for sale to
customer and self-builders
we have continued concern that no
community asset is being proposed by the
developer
there is a lack of pedestrian cycle
connectivity
from the development to the surrounding
areas and camden road
increased links should be provided to
surrounding areas including camden road
to encourage walking cycling rather than
car use
there is a lack of tree planting within
the development
and finally the current proposals are
not in accordance with
course strategy policy cs2 and the
emerging supplementary planning document
part
five whilst town council acknowledges
the comments regarding the medical
center option on the applicant's land is
not a planning consideration
we are very concerned that this option
could be curtailed
thus prejudicing the existing medical
center's plans for a new enlarged center
before they have been finalized
if the application is approved the town
council requests that the following
conditions are included
new roundabout on camden road as
required for the adjacent development
is constructed before development takes
place on the applicant's site
no development commence until the land
option held by the medical center has
been formally withdrawn by the medical
center
wheel cleaning is required for all
vehicles exiting the site to prevent mud
and debris being deposited on the public
highway
a construction management plan to be
submitted and approved prior to
commencement of the development and must
include access route details
working hours maximum noise levels dust
suppression procedures control of mud
and wheel cleaning
and the control and disposal of waste
set
working hours to be restricted to 0 700
to 1800
hours monday to friday and 8 30 to uh
11 o'clock on uh sorry one o'clock on
saturdays
psych deliveries prohibited during
school arrival departure times
all contractors vehicles are to park
within the site cartilage
uh contractors vehicles to be prohibited
from parking on camden road at any time
for whatever period
the adjacent attenuation pond must be
completed before the development
condenses and run off control during
construction to prevent
surface water runoff uh on the
properties
on pitway avenue or electric power
charging points can be provided for each
dwelling
this test i'm afraid i'm
that's quite all right um i did make an
effort to write down a lot of the
conditions that you you've come up with
i've got the majority of them i'm hoping
that
um that our planning managers have done
the same
um if you could just bear with i'm going
to seek some questions from our members
um members if you could indicate in the
chat if you
uh if you have anything you would like
to ask counselor tash
it looks like that might be a no um so
counselor
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening it's great
appreciated um you probably best off
hanging up the phone and continuing to
watch
on the uh the live stream elsewhere but
um
thank you thank you again for your for
your contribution pleasure thank you
very much
for listening to me no problem thank you
okay we will move to our next speaker
who is mr matthew
williams mr williams is the agent for
the application
mr williams if you press start and six
on your keypad we should hopefully be
able to hear you
uh hopefully i'm no longer muted you are
no longer muted we can hear you
very clearly um i think you know the
drill you've got three minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready please begin thank
you chair
good evening and thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today
my name is matthew williams and i'm here
on behalf of the applicant's partner
construction
part of construction of the building
contractor for the site and once
developed a housing association will
take ownership
and maintenance of the land should
planning commission be granted
at the outset i'd like to thank your
officers for providing a very
professional service throughout the
pre-application and application stages
of the project
the guidance has been consistent helpful
and well considered
this has resulted in a strong
recommendation for approval because what
will be delivered as a sustainable and
beneficial affordable housing scheme
i'm just going to move away from my
script slightly here because
i just wanted to reassure members that
actually all of those conditions and the
points raised by the town council
have been considered in absolute detail
with the planning offices
i would note that all of those
conditions are addressed and we we've
dealt with those
through the conditions and
pre-commencement conditions and
agreements that are being put forward by
eddie wrench in relation to
the option the medical center are fully
aware and
no longer require the land that is the
discussions we've had with them they do
not object to the application
and irrespective of that it is not a
planning consideration
in respect of other matters raised by
objections objectives
these are addressed through
contributions for off-site open space to
allow a scheme
of improvement within the town to be
delivered that benefits a much wider
area of the community
there is more than sufficient open space
within the wider housing development
therefore further on-site open space is
not necessary
the site is accepted as being very well
connected to the town centre for
pedestrians and cyclists
there is no statutory objection in
respect of highways matters
detailed landscape plans have been
provided contrary to the comments of mr
tesh
these plans include tree planting
throughout the scheme and introduce
beneficial native planting species to an
extensive new hedge along the eastern
boundary
in terms of the benefits of the scheme
it will deliver 65
much-needed affordable homes it will
provide a mix of one two three and four
bed houses
including bungalows and this mix has
been fully welcomed by the council's
development and policy enabler
the split of tenure between social rent
and shared ownership
which is a form of home ownership will
provide a welcome addition to the
housing mix locally
and will provide opportunities for
families on lower incomes to remain and
work in the area where they are well
established
this will lead to more inclusive and
balanced in its community
the homes will be energy efficient they
include secure cycle parking
policy compliant parking spaces electric
vehicle charging points for every home
water bots for every home and will meet
all design standards for space around
dwellings including separation distances
with existing dwellings
that comply with your design guidelines
in summary
officers conclude that the development
is policy compliant there is no
submitted evidence to the contrary
and a high standard of residential
amenity will be achieved for all
existing and future occupiers
i really do hope the committee members
agree with these conclusions and approve
the application today
thank you for your time mr williams
thank you very much for that
we do have some questions for you so
first up is councillor
parry thank you
thank you chairman um and good evening
to you sir
um i just wonder on the basis that you
mentioned you've already got a housing
association lined up if you can just
explain
the rationale for the the viability your
financial viability
assessment means it falls way short
of um fairly standard contributions
to the community perhaps you could just
give some um
further information on that for me
please thank you
sure thank you councillor yeah the
the viability assessment has been
undertaken on the basis of an affordable
housing scheme
and what it would be expected to pay in
relation to
sale and the regulation 123 list
that list would originally have
contributed towards schools but there's
been a change as you will be aware to
infrastructure funding statements during
this process
um particularly because of the slowdown
with covid
now we've sought to address that through
providing
um a the the most amount of affordable
housing contribute sorry the most amount
of contributions that we can
and through discussions with officers
that'd be viability tested and have been
put forward to what they consider to be
the most appropriate
uh matters of infrastructure in the
community
it's fine lovely thank you um
councillor fleming has a question for
you cancer flooding over to you
oh thank you chairman um just a question
there's an
absolute absence of any play equipment
for children and why should you say
there's public open space in the locale
is it walkable in a safe way for parents
of young children
because obviously this type of housing
state is going to attract a lot of
families
is this play equipment or public open
space close enough
um to warrant the the fact that there'd
be no danger for these people to get to
it
thank you council that's a that's a very
valid question
and one that we did research fully uh in
making the decision to do an off-site
contribution
it's dealt with by mr wrench in the
committee report
it's less than 400 meters through the
taylor wimpy development
along the same streets and roads which
have been found acceptable for that
scheme
to the uh significantly well equipped
play space
at the top of the scheme the approach
here was to provide a contribution
because we did have
discussions with the town council prior
to the application being submitted
and there is land within the town centre
where there's a very nice scheme which
we costed and put fees to
which would be a much wider benefit to
the local community and that
i hope and due course and it's for the
council to determine
maybe a scheme that could be put forward
and funded with the contribution from
this scheme thank you very much members
do you have any other questions i have
no one listed to speak at the moment but
if you have any more now is your time
see some shaking heads so i'm going to
assume that some know so mr williams
thank you once again for your
contribution this evening if you want to
continue to watch through the live
broadcast on your
laptop tablet or pc uh that's probably
the best way to
do it but thank you once again for your
input this evening
many thanks chair and thank you
councilman thank you
okay uh we'll move to our next and final
speaker on this item which is councillor
joe barker council barca are you
there with us i'm here can you hear me
we can indeed well blended splendid
see i think you know the drill you've
got five minutes we'll give you a 30
second warning
whenever you're ready feel free to start
thank you
um i should perhaps put in context
exactly who and what i am because i'm
not just
district councillor for this patch and
for the for this application i'm also
the county councillor i'm also a town
councillor covering the same patch so i
would associate myself completely
with what councillor tesh has said um i
know they i know that the town council
not me but uh the other members of town
council had discussions
i have had discussions with developers
um myself
i'm glad to see that the one thing that
i was really banging on about which was
uh water butts
have actually uh now because they've
come through in policy we're getting
them
but that leads into the first tale of
woe that i need to tell you about this
site
um we refer to foul water at drainage
and sewers
and i i have become addicted to such
underwater
containers of foul things because
the sewers and the drainage in shipstand
are insufficient
for what they have to do it was
interesting that i think it was one of
eddie's photographs was taken on a very
very very wet day
we were lucky there wasn't actually a
river running down the road or down the
runners down the side where we where
we've had some extraordinary flows
recently
what we've had down in down the hill
further into the town
is over topping and the over topic has
meant that we've had plenty of poo
sloshing about
in the streets and in people's gardens
so
i'm working with the flood team with my
county councillors hat on in fact we're
trundling around shipston uh looking at
our sewers and gullies um
on thursday but it is a real problem and
it's something that
seriously needs to be considered in this
one um
because there's been a total failure in
the past two um
ten over ten years ago this all started
and the good denizens of shipstone
were persuaded by their councillors at
the time that they were going to get a
medical center
and that they were going to get a
supermarket and on the back
of those two things and i see councilor
mills who was around at the time
nodding on the back of that support was
given to the
really quite enormous amount of
development that has happened if you
refer back to the beginning of this
report
the number of sites that actually join
together
we were never going to get a supermarket
there was an option there was a bit of
land for a supermarket that's already
been built over
no supermarkets wanted to come
the medical center may have given up
their
option on this site i don't know i have
no evidence
to suggest that that is the case at the
moment
but the one condition that i really want
is in the same way as you can have a
unilateral under
undertaking on a a horn beam
hedge you can have an undertaking on
what happens to that option
so i would disagree i think that is a
planning consideration
and i really want to see that option
left with the town possibly in the
person of the town council
so that it can be that option can then
be exercised for a community use
so that we actually get something out
of the many hundreds of houses that
we've had built
for the community because that option
for the medical center is not going to
be exercised
because that because that's going to be
taking place at the ellen badger
hospital which exists at present
um so basically whilst i'm totally
supportive of
this application i'm delighted at seeing
so many affordable housing
particularly as i'm the housing
portfolio holder i do have some serious
considerations as you've heard
um and on a slightly lighter note apart
from the poo
and the over topping i'd i would love it
if we could have
peter barnes memorial bird boxes you
know the ones i mean which are the
bricks that are actually built in
um we've got the water butts i'd like
some broadband connections that actually
were broadband connections to the
property
which can be put in at the time much
more cheaply rather than
just a box on people's walls which is
what they often find
and i have one final concern and this is
my county council hat on i'm also the
chair of governors of the local primary
school
whilst i understand the viability
assessments is only saying 109
000 the contribution for this many
properties
with the number of children that would
be in it to education should be
more like half a million pounds and i'm
concerned
at that difference that's a lot of
education of a lot of kids
thank you fantastic thank you councillor
barker
members do we have any questions for our
ward member
i can see lots of shaking heads and not
much action it looks like
you've got a got away with it tonight
councillor barker so thank you very much
for your contribution
very helpful uh feel free to hang around
and continue to watch as we uh debate
and deliberate
okay uh in that case let's move to uh
what's clarification for our officer do
we have any
points clarification or questions the
officer
i cannot see much action at the moment
oh counselor jennings is in oh blimey
everyone's coming in now
council jenny do you want to uh do you
want to start off
thank you gentlemen just a quick bit of
clarification on the
on the sewage which has been brought up
and
drink water i presume have been
i've looked at this and okayed it or
uh yes they've made a formal
representation um
they haven't raised objection uh what
they have raised is that
uh any connection under the water
industry act i think 1991
is that the applicant would need to make
a separate application
for connections to the sewage system in
the local area
so that would be done under separate
legislation to the planning legislation
but they're not raising objection that
there's a
particular issue on this point they've
only advised us
a suggested informative so a note at the
end of any
permission if it was forthcoming uh
advising that of the applicant of the
process they need to go through to
connect to the
the main sewer so basically something
outside of
outside of our jurisdiction yeah yeah
it's outside of planning so yeah they
need to apply
that as if they gained planning then
they still need to make applications
yeah to the
local um seven trend basically to for
those connections and
obviously if works need to be done to
improve it that
seven trent would need to secure that
themselves
thank you marvelous thank you very much
councillor parry
to you
um council thank you chairman councillor
jennings stole my thunder i was going to
ask something very very similar which
has been
answered by eddie wrench thank you no
problem at all
he does do that sometimes counselor edin
you have a question thank you chair um
councillor tesh mentioned
their ndp in a policy that i think they
said was h
s g i've written down seven but i think
it might have been eight
about the twenty percent being uh built
in it not conforming to that i can't see
any mention of the ndp in the report but
i might have missed it
yeah there was a there's a short part in
them the update sheet
with regards to that um i can just
if you'd like me to detail what it said
but basically yeah there there's there's
a policy which encourages a certain
amount of um
self-built properties and the the theory
behind this is basically to
increase affordable houses or allow
people for more affordable houses within
the area
so basically in policy terms because
this is a 100 affordable scheme
the aims of that policy are considered
to align
to this development as it's still
providing affordable housing
and you know allowing local people to
buy the property so it's felt by
officers that there's no
um contradiction between providing 100
affordable housing which is
within the ndp also supported in terms
of
applications which provide 100
affordable as well
so that that's basically what conclusion
we've come to
lovely thank you and finally councilman
mills
so thanks mr chairman my question was
about
sewers of course and uh eddie has
answered that question so thank you very
much mr chairman
fabulous okay well unless we've got any
any further points of clarification we
will move into our debate who
would like to start off with the debate
councillor jennings good man council
jennings over to you
well so i think it's one as far as i can
see it's just
quite cut and dry really and i can see
no material planning reasons to object
to the application
and therefore i'd like to propose to
grant this application
subject to the conditions laid out by
the officer or any other
conditions which the committee may
seem feel fit to impose
lovely stuff uh councillor mills
uh yes thanks mr chairman yes i i'm
looking at the uh
the agenda and i mean i think this is
great you know 65 homes
affordable housing there's a mixture of
bungalows there as well
and if the um developer is um
wanting to uh uh adhere to the
to the conditions i think i think it's
it's it's a great site so um
i'm quite for this mr chairman thank you
if you're still muted cancer kendall
[Music]
cancer kendall are you can you hear
good man there me go sorry the computer
glitched i couldn't get it to i'm new
sorry about that
um everything has been said that i would
like to back up uh i'd happily third it
if it was possible
lovely will we consider that third in
that case
okay um in that case unless there are
any other
uh members that we should contribute to
the debate i'm seeing lots of shakes
head shaking heads uh we will move
towards a vote in that case
so the proposal is to grant in line with
the officer's recommendation subject to
the s106 and including any information
that was included in the
update sheet i will start us off
councillor richards
four thank you chairman councillor
fleming
council fleming abstain councillor
kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crump
councillor councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor eden
council reading four councillor henshaw
seraphin
thanks for helping serif in for thank
you
councillor jennings councillor joining
us for
councillor mills council mills for
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
thank you that's 94 chairman with one
abstention
fabulous thank you very much liz so
therefore committee resolves to
grant uh application twenty zero zero
three four three ful as land
north of camden road and ships and on
star fabulous
um we will take another uh two minutes
to bring in the speakers for our next
item which is in low braille so two
minutes
once again if you could please mute all
your microphones remember we are still
being broadcast
okay members we have all of our speakers
in the meeting now they're all muted
ready to go so if i could please bring
your attention
back to your screens
that would be great
hopefully you'll be able to see me
shortly any lucky things
okay good we are back and ready to go so
um next item
is application twenty zero one six five
nine ful that's land off sutton lane in
lower brailles
our presenting officer is joe brook so
joe
over to you whenever you're ready thank
you chair uh let me just
upload the presentation
the application site is located at the
southern western edge of lower brailles
as indicated by the black dot
for you the application is also
contained within the console
aomb
the application is seeking permission to
erect a four bedroom
open market dwelling at the southern
eastern corner of an open parcel land
which was within the application
boundary
for 13-03-166-08
this would prove the erection of 18
dwellings were associated public open
space
so these are the 18 dwellings that have
been already approved and
these have already been built and these
are currently under construction
this is plot 19 which is part proposal
which is currently
part of the open space as you can see
before you
the development of the dwelling is
proposed in the open space
as part of it and it would therefore
take away
roughly 443 33 square meters of open
space
if permitted the application would see
the development of a single four-bedroom
detached dwelling
the dwelling is proposed to be set at
7.7 meters in height
to ridge with an overall bill for a
built footprint of 127 square meters
and 254 square meters over two floors
the drilling will be constructed of
slate roofing natural horns and stone
and timber windows
and will be situated as a corner plot
the house will be done frontier with an
active
elevation facing north of the
residential state
proceeding over the countryside with the
rear elevation
this is a street scene and the dwelling
will be cut into the ground level so you
can
see this is the existing uh building to
it this is a supposed dwelling the ridge
height would be set lower
because it will be cut into the ground
level
and therefore settler so we come to the
photographs
this is obviously the houses under
construction here's the public open
space
if permitted this is where the dwelling
would be cited
as you can see the open countryside to
rio
these are dwellings have already been
built on sites they give you a good
indication of what the dwelling would be
uh would look like if permitted um
parking situated to the front natural
stone
so this is part of the dwelling along
tommy turns
lane as you can see by the arrow looking
upwards uh
it would be sighted roughly just there
as you can see already the buildings
have been built
and this is the dwelling that's
currently under construction
it's just coming down the prowl so these
are dwellings
and it would be sighted just in between
there so there is in this
inverse gaps and it would be set lower
than that dwelling as shown on the
street see
and this is off certain lane so as
indicated by the hour there this is
coming into the village
so these are the dwellings that exist
those one is just there to the west of
the site
and the view of it would be set just
behind there so
as you can see there is significant
hedgerow already along certain lane
and that's the end of the presentation i
sat on the officer report the
application
is considered to comply with all policy
requirements including the small loss of
the public open space
overall the pros dwelling would respect
the existing financial australian built
form
in terms of size scale mass and height
and would be viewed in the wider
landscape as an infield development when
he exists in
residential estate officer
recommendation is there for approval
there are no updates thank you joe thank
you very much for that well done um
okay we will bring our first speaker in
uh in that case which is uh councillor
tony aschel from braille's parish
council
council ashley are you there you may
need to press star and six to unmute
yourself
to reiterate that star and six should i
meet you mr asheville or council
asheville sorry i should say
can you hear us
we can hear you loud and clear thank you
very much
okay excellent you've got three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second
warning uh and then if you can stay on
uh afterwards for any questions that
members may have
as soon as you're ready feel free to
start okay
okay um right braille price
are counselor to this basically along
three three lines
um the first one is this application
will be another interesting on the
earlier about standing that's the beauty
the different buildings on the site is
under 1303 166
but visible from any number of footpaths
and highways
and the ctr really pointed out that
these are a certain extent shielded by a
ridge of high ground
this new proposal will not be as well
concealed further
policy cs9 says proposals will include
appropriate landscaping to create places
where people will want to live work and
visit and must be sensitive to
and integrate with the existing built
form landscape carrots and topography of
the site and not harm public views
the neighborhood development plan which
has just been recently ratified
further supports and adds to this
sentiment uh the policy
objective e3 is to locally secure the
district-wide strategic aim of
maintaining and enhancing
rural character and local
distinctiveness this requires the
effects and conservation of several
publicly accessible green spaces within
the village
as your officer just said 20 of one of
these green spaces will be partly used
to accommodate the planned property
this green space is intended as an
immunity for the houses that are
currently either exist that are being
built to get into the slate in question
existing properties have gardens but
these in the main are quite small
and given the current constraint force
department by kobe 19
those mean these may not be sufficient
immunity to offset the health problems
both physical and mental that we are now
seeing in the country
provision of open spaces is now
important and more than ever
and both the core strategy and envy
scene three it's important that local
authorities cause strategies and not
bypass
further when circling clash r316 out was
approved
one of the conditions forward by
structured this will counter was that
the development here by committed should
be restricted to a maximum
of 18 dwellings and it would be a big
surprise if sbc breached their own plan
conditions
quite quickly the core strategies
housing allocations have rails to take
four houses neighborhood development
plans signed off by sdc demonstrates
that 79 houses will be built in the
period of 2011
to 2031 and with additional windfall
houses
this target will be easily met without
the proposed property despite the claims
from the
uh african sbc is well ahead of its
five-year housing land
target we've considered with this quite
within the community regarding the
transportation
and this goes against both the core
strategy and the neighborhood
development plan and we ask that this
application is with you
marvelous uh mr old council sorry thank
you very much for that just bear with me
i will seek
members uh if they have any questions
members if you could indicate in the
meeting chat that would be great
i'm not seeing any questions coming
forward uh councillor ashel
i think i think we're good to go so oh
hang on councilman mills is waving at me
councilman do you have a question i i
did i did put in the speak
bit but um anyhow um uh good evening
um was there a any consultation
uh with the parish council from the
developer on this uh
on this uh further application
i'm gonna say not to my knowledge
right okay thank you
okay we have another question then from
councillor jennings jennings when you're
ready
good evening council so you mentioned
that there's been
considerable disquieter to your
objection to this
application um
i was just trying to see how many people
have objected
do you know do you know how many people
have objected to this
i think it's 16 4 and 18 against i think
okay thanks very much and the eighteen
against were basically uh people within
the village
not related to any applicants or
anything
thank you okay thank you very much for
that both of you um i don't see any
further questions
for you uh mr ash also oh sorry i keep
saying mr councillor
i should say um so i don't see any other
questions coming forward say it again
sorry
that's very kind thank you um there are
no more questions so um if you want to
continue to watch
uh on the online portal uh so either
through our website or through i think
it's on youtube as well
that's probably the best way to do it
but thank you for your contribution this
evening okay thank you
thank you thanks okay we will move to
our next speaker who
is uh mr andrew murphy the agent mr
murphy again star six
to unmutual i can you've done this
before
you were very quick there good man yeah
you know the gig so uh three minutes 30
second warning when you're ready
tomorrow right thank you chairman uh the
application site is part of a larger
site currently under construction with
18 houses
of which fourteen are affordable and
four are local market units
it is proposed to build a nineteenth
house on the site which is an open
market house
as a corner plot the house will be
double fronted
its design layout and materials will
complement the 18 other houses
and its position will round off the
horseshoe layout of the new estate
its garden is twice as twice as large as
the council standards
it will be cut into the ground with its
ridge height lower than the nearby
houses under construction
when viewed from across the fields the
adjacent plot 8 will be seen as the
taller house
furthermore the neighborhood plan
identifies several important viewpoints
around the village
however none of those viewpoints are
located near to this site
the plot involves losing part of the
future public open space that will
eventually serve the 18 houses under
construction
however the public open space is very
large four times larger than the
council's minimum standard
building a 19th house will still result
in a massively surplus public open space
three and a half times larger than the
council's requirements
furthermore the plot is only a small
part of the future public open space
located on an offshoot in the corner
that is poorly overlooked
and too small for sports and recreation
and with a little amenity value
there are more letters of support for
this proposal than there are objectives
you can look at the committee report to
find that out now some objectives
mention conflict and neighborhood plan
policy e3 as did the parish council just
now
and that policy seeks to protect local
green spaces and those
green spaces are identified in the
neighborhood plan however this site is
not
a local green space it's not identified
as such
and so there is no conflict with
neighborhood plan policy e3
the proposed house is located within the
build a built-up area boundary of
brailles
the neighborhood plan states that
development proposals will be supported
within the built-up area boundary and
through and i quote
the more efficient use of land within
the existing settlement
for housing and other appropriate types
of developments
development in accordance with this
policy will meet the expectations of the
nppf concerning the efficient use of
land
the core strategy target for brailles is
84 houses
whereby only 48 nine so whereby only 49
houses
are built or committed so far according
according to the latest monitoring
figures
clearly this proposal should be
supported in principle
it constitutes a valuable windfall house
that makes more efficient use of land
and contributes to meeting the unmet
housing needs of brailles
therefore i ask you to support the
officer recommendation and grant
planning permission
thank you
mr murphy thank you very much for that
um members do we have any questions for
our agent
i say our agent the applications agent
i'm not saying any activity
mr murphy looks like you've covered
everything so thank you very much for
your contribution this evening thank you
again feel free to watch uh through the
the live broadcast
i will do yes okay thank you thanks very
much cheers
um okay we'll move to our final speaker
on this item then which is councillor
wally hoggins
council hoggins castle wally hogan sorry
are you there
i'm here hello sorry i'm just shining my
torch on my writing so i can actually
read it good evening everybody good
evening
i think you know the drill five minutes
30 second warning whenever you're ready
feel free to start
the most significant picture shown by
officer brooks this evening was the one
which showed the hillside in the
background of the horseshoe it was
sort of a wider picture so i ask that
you have a look at that
perhaps at the end of my speech today
because that gives you what you are
considering today
i'm here this evening to speak against
the proposed development
i am in fact a gas that this
opportunistic application has been made
this plan seeks to increase the number
of houses on a site given very
particular conditions
regarding housing numbers in two
thousand fifteen
condition four in the original planning
commission stated
the development hereby permitted shall
be restricted to a maximum of 18
dwellings
the original development was given very
careful scrutiny and it is significant
at the cotswold conservation board
sought for the original application to
be rejected and stratfor district
council committee report
also sought to find a balance between
benefit and harm
this balance would be greatly harmed by
the addition of this 19th house
and makes a mockery of the original
granted application
and the amenities afforded to those
choosing to live in the original
18 houses um as their livestock will be
significantly
reduced which is profoundly unfair by
the fact that this land was supposed to
remain
an open space with uninterrupted views
to the
um to the hillside beyond the large
public open space
integral to the original plan was seen
by the stratfor district council
committee
and consultees as a crucial
mitigation as the harm the estate may
cause especially due to the small
gardens that the houses there have
this application would remove at least
20 percent of this estate's
public open space and views to the open
countryside of the area of outstanding
natural beauty the campaign for rurally
of
england objects strongly to this
application because of its
impact on the cotswold area of
outstanding natural beauty
cs9 cs1 cs5 and c cs7 should be
considered
along with policy cs11 the stratfor
district council core strategy's housing
target for brails
up to 2031 is 84.
in the page 36 of the braille's
neighborhood development plan
clearly demonstrates that 79 houses have
been built
given permission or will be allocated
sites
so with windfall houses and conversion
the target of another five houses will
be comfortably met
in the next 11 years without the need to
build
this house the neighborhood development
plan
also lists and notes the local green
spaces and highlights the value
given to all of the green spaces
even those not specified within the
village
it's worthy of note however that this
green space
didn't necessarily exist
when the neighborhood development plan
was listed
was written sorry
the green spaces are particularly
important to brailles because
of the fact that it's in the area of
outstanding natural beauty
and this additional house will destroy a
very significant
green space it's a tranquil area where
the minimization of noise traffic
congestion and light pollution is a
priority
it must not harm of his the historic
character this is
exactly what this is going to do and it
is going to detract
from the landscape and the
distinctiveness of living within
this part of the cotswold area of
natural beauty
furthermore the plants are physically
cut into the green space to create a
lower ground level for this house is
totally contrary to the visual
psychological and historic character of
the village
and could potentially be ecologically
harmful and the planned sitting room and
kitchen dining room on the first floor
and as such they will overlook some of
the bedrooms in properties
in miller's way
i urge you to reconsider this is the
cotswold area of outstanding natural
beauty we are looking at the impact this
will have
uh for all residents of brailles because
there will be obliteration of a key view
and i urge you to look at that
photograph currently shown um by the
officer
earlier on in his presentation i'm just
going to check my notes
thank you
and that's it thank you very much indeed
thank you very much councillor
joe would you mind bringing up the slide
so that it's on our screens and while
you're doing that counselor parry has
indicated she'd like to ask a question
so i shall ask that's
probably to do that very thing thank you
good evening councillor wally hoggins
i just wonder whether you can explain
in a little bit more detail how the
construction of this house being
adjacent to 18 others
is harmful to
the anob um in its context sitting
with 18 other properties okay it isn't
this isn't
i will uh counselor parry of course but
actually i need to photograph
it so a wide view of the houses with a
view of the hills at the back
um officer brooks if you could bring
that one up for me
it was more of the houses with the view
of the hills uh no
probably the one before that i think
sorry just trying to my system's been
really slow
all right no oh
that one there yes so there can you see
to the side of that there you've got the
hat the the hillside
there with the with the trees on the top
so that will be completely obliterated
and that was
why this um area of green space was left
and it was this particular
fact that in 2015 when the original
planning permission was granted
that it was for only 18 houses and it's
you know and it's because of that and
this development here using this space
was approved because it
leaves exactly that view that is so
um so particular to the cotswold area
about suddenly natural beauty
you know and if you build a house right
in front of that you then obscure
the significant part of the cotswold
area standing natural beauty
which is the hillside and and the
countryside
okay thank you very much um members do
we have any further questions
seen lots of shaking heads
no okay in that case uh councilwood
hogan thank you very much for
contribution this evening please feel
free to stay on while we uh
deliberate discuss and debate
okay uh that's all our speakers so
members do we have any questions for our
officer
counselor jennings council journey has
indicated a question
yes sorry could you bring up that last
photo please
sorry
i'm like am i correct that that photo is
being taken from
within that this development of 18
houses
you are correct let me show you the site
plan so you know exactly where i took
it it was approximately there
so you're looking across from there so
you come into the
avenue like that and like these houses
are built and i was about there when i
took
it looking over so yeah so therefore you
have to drive into that drive and go to
that unit
you have to so there you go the location
plan so you have to come down this is
the main route coming into braille
you have to go into the estate so past
these dwellings here
and then into the area so the photo is
about there in the estate
and that's where the dwelling is being
proposed so the view is looking straight
over
there is a public footpath as you saw in
my photos i did also walk along that
public footpath
and the dwellings here are obviously
situated in between
okay thank you very much okay
uh we also have questions from
councillor parry caspari
sorry currents i can't hear
um the question i wanted to the question
i wanted to ask
from a technical perspective is to what
weight
should we be given to um
rationale for previous planning
permissions that the committee approved
to keep
certain areas of green space open
and not built on and how does that sit
in terms of the call the call strategy
that if
if the original development was granted
on the basis
of the views to the anob and the green
space
to protect that view what weight
does that actually hold in terms of this
new application
i'll be honest it's not so much weight
it's a material consideration so the
reason being that i've come to my
conclusion and sell out the report is
that
that application was submitted in 2013
and it was also
determined in 2015 so you obviously do
have the conditions but since then the
core strategy was adopted in 2016 the
ndp came adopted in 2019 and the spd was
adopted in 2019 as well
also supporting the core strategies i've
highlighted
they did do a landscape visual impact
assessment and i've also gone down there
to assess
how it impacts some how i've set it
on the area around so since our approval
there's been a lot
of new documents that are all adopted
that have changed that sort of outcome
in my professional opinion that it was
approved in 2015.
there is a material consideration um
but it's kind of what you get that
weight wise
it's it's hard to say weight-wise
because it's still
a lot an old application it's just you
also have to obviously go with the new
most up-to-date adopted policy
thank you lovely thank you very much
cancer dixon you have a question
thank you chairman joe when assessing
uh the need and the requirements for
public open space
do we look at developments as a
individual
separate entity or can public space be
required from a development
to meet a shortfall elsewhere within the
the parish or the the community as such
it's a good question uh it can be
applied to both uh to be honest um
in this case because it's not been
recognized in the ndp and the reason
that it was
originally done was because of the 2013
application
it's been assessed on that basis because
it was approved as part of that 2013
application
if it was recognized in the ndp then you
would have to do a wider assessment for
the whole area
often it is normally from the
applications so normally very large
schemes
uh such as lighthorn heath and so forth
where you would have a thousand people
and therefore you need to
get the additional requirements so in
this case because it was approved in
2013
well proven 2015 it's a part of that
assessment
and it hasn't been allocated in the ndp
so so it's a case by case basis but for
this reason i've assessed it
on the 2013 application
thank you joe thank you joe
thank you both um last question is from
councillor hendrick serafin
thank you chair uh joseph uh
the 18 residents in that development
are there any objections from those
i'll be perfectly honest karen sir and i
think i've highlighted that in my report
i know there's been issues with
um whether there was false
representation the honest truth is
i don't have the remit as an officer
to go out and double check who is the
person that submitted their comments
all i can do is um analyze the comments
and take on material planning
considerations
which i've set out i've read every
single comment i've set out what
material considerations have been stated
and then i've come to my conclusion in
my report i can't comment who
actually has or hasn't commented
specifically
i think in in this respect uh councillor
surfing what's important for members to
focus on
is the matters that are raised by any
comments
um from the planning point of view in
terms of legislation it's irrelevant
uh where somebody lives everybody is
entitled to comment on a planning
application
what members need to focus on is if
there are any uh planning considerations
that have been raised
that members weigh significantly either
for or against the application
and how they relate to the development
plan policies
um that we currently have adopted
okay another question joseph was i have
concerns about
um green open spaces that were
there originally and now there's going
to be a certain amount
taken away does this leave it open to
any development now that's had green
open spaces passed in the past
um that is my concern about that
fundamentally no
because the honest truth is every
application has to be determined on its
own merits and constraints
so it has to come down to what's been
applied in this instance
they in my opinion demonstrated there is
a
quite a significant surplus in
requirements of the new spd
and also in respect to the landscape
harm and so forth
doesn't warrant a refusal um
elsewhere it would also come down to the
same merits and constraints of the
application
so no it would have to be assessed on
that basis of that application that
comes in
okay thank you if if a major star chair
through you is that okay
uh you can yeah i just draw members
attention to
um page 54 of the agenda which deals
with these matters in respect
of public open space um i think joseph's
sets out really well policy cs25
of the council's core strategy sets out
open space standards
it is a newer policy than the old
planning
commission which was adopted
times do change and there is even newer
supplementary planning guidance which
further details um what levels of public
open space would be required
the ndp did have an opportunity to
safeguard this open
space if it felt it was appropriate to
do so but didn't
and so the policies which are relevant
to the determination of the application
are the core strategy policy and the
guidance in the spd
both of which point members towards the
fact that there's sufficient open space
for the dwellings proposed
lovely thank you um mina you've
indicated you'd like to speak i'm
guessing it may have been covered
uh by uh uh by david jeffery but if
you'd like to speak now please
do um thank you yeah just to add in
on material planning considerations um
the previous speaker mentioned about
views of the hillside
so um loss of a private view from a
window
is not a material planning consideration
but
loss of public views for example from a
public footpath
would be a material planning
consideration so that's just something
members may want to weigh in a way in
terms of the balancing
exercise they do on material planning
considerations
lovely thank you very much for that uh
okay members do we have any further
questions
for uh for joe before we move to our
debates
i see lots of shaking heads i'm going to
assume that's a no so
let's move into debate who would like to
start
don't all jump at once
councilor mills
thank you mr chairman um i had to say
i'm a little bit concerned
about this um when the developer first
uh puts application in it was for 18
dwellings has been mentioned before
um if they've gone for 19 perhaps they
wouldn't have got it i don't know
but they've now gone for another one is
taking
and they knowingly taking over taking
over this
uh open space um
to me it's not quite right mr chairman
um
i'll put some thought to this but at the
moment i'm
edging to go against the officer's
recommendation on this but
i'll put some more thought to it thank
you
understood thank you councillor mills
councillor parry
thank you chairman um i can understand
the concerns raised by the parish
council
and the ward member
however and i am actually really very
sympathetic to them
but if we just look at the material
planning reasons behind all of this
we still have some green space that is
bigger than our current current policy
provides
um the site is
within the built-up area boundary so
would
qualifies on a windfall windfall site
the only area that i have a big concern
with
is the the loss of this view
of this hill with the with the trees um
and my concern is that developers would
take it to appeal
um and i think on grounds
purely on material planning reasons
i'm going to have to go with the
officer's recommendation
thank you councillor perry is that a
formal proposal
yeah happy propose thank you very much
uh councillor jennings you've uh
indicated you'd like to speak
yes thank you chairman um obviously the
a little bit of information about the
view is has to be from a public footpath
it's already obscured
by the houses which are there and i
think the office
has done a been very thorough on this
particular application
he's gone he seems to have gone through
it with a fine tooth comb
i'm happy that all the policy are being
met
i can't see any uh material planning
reasons to object to the application so
i'm happy to second it
marvellous thank you very much i can see
councillor dixon has launched in and
seconded in big capital letters just now
as well so
um counselor kendall you've indicated
you'd like to speak
yeah thank you chairman um same as
what's been said really i
i do share uh councillor mills concerns
i i think
what counts me i don't know what
councilman's things but really
maybe his concerns are coming around the
way this has been handled i don't like
the way a
house has been added i completely agree
with that but like councilor parry says
and everybody else said
there are no material grounds to go
against
so i will also uh follow the officer's
recommendation
thank you marvelous thank you much uh we
have a proposal and a seconder
um casa mills did you want to come back
you you said you might come back later
on
don't feel you have to you can change
your head um
only we've seen this time and again mr
chairman
that um an application comes in for
development
and uh they get the application grant
and they think all
let's try and stick another one in and
you know it's all retrospective
um for one for better words taken to
mickey
um we i just see it time and time again
where um
the developer just gets greedy uh mr
chairman
thank you thank you council mills um
yes i think we do see it uh fairly
frequently and i don't think it's gonna
stop anytime soon
they are operating within the planning
framework uh we have to make decisions
what's based
in front of us um okay so we have a
proposal
we have a seconder uh the proposal
is to uh grant in line with the
officer's
recommendation um i will go first and i
will say council richards
four thank you chairman councillor
fleming
councillor fleming reluctantly for thank
you
councillor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor cramp for
councillor dixon councillor dixon
four sorry chairman i hit the caps lock
um during the four minute recess don't
worry
councillor eden council reading
against councillor henshaw serafin
councillor henshasterafin against
councillor jennings councillor jennings
for
councillor mills councillor mills
against
and councillor parry councillor parry
for
that's seven four chairman and three
against
really thank you very much so uh
committee therefore resolves
to uh grant application twenty zero one
six five nine fuel
is land off sutton lane in lower rails
uh in line with the opera officer
recommendation um we will take another
two minutes while we call in our
speakers for our final item so two
minutes please remember to mute your
microphones we are still being broadcast
live
members we're just having a slight
technical glitch in getting a couple of
people into the meeting so just bear
with us another couple of minutes while
we do that
okay members sorry about that slight
technical uh hiccup trying to get
a couple of our speakers into our
meeting but we are there we've overcome
it
and we are good to go so if i could
please draw your attentions back to your
screens
and we will very shortly beginning our
next application
so the application is application
reference twenty zero one
six zero zero f u l that is san barn
farm central road in hampton lucy
our presenting officer is eddie wrench
eddie whenever you're ready
over to you
thank you chair uh the application
uh samba samban farm
is for the erection of a detached oak
frame pool building
uh the site is located around 500
meters north of hampton lucy as denoted
here by the
black dot in center of the screen
this aerial view shows the approximate
location of the proposed
uh pool house in relation to the main
dwelling
the main dwelling is here which is a
grade two listed
former farm house in the open
countryside
the distance between the host dwelling
and the proposed barn is around
30 meters wall to wall
here are some proposed uh elevations of
the pool house
um it would measure approximately seven
meters 17 meters by nine meters
and around 4.7 meters to the ridge
this is a view from within the existing
garden of the property
the main house is on the right hand side
here
the proposed pool house would be located
just beyond
the vegetation here so just the other
side of that
and finally just a context plan with the
main house
shown here the pool house would be
located uh just to the left of the house
as we look at it
beyond this vegetation here
uh chair the proposal is to refuse the
application for the reasons on pages
68 and 69 of the agenda thank you very
much
marvelous eddie thank you very much okay
we will go straight to
our first speaker who is cancer alex
jones from hampton lucy parish council
castle jones you will need to press star
and six in order to unmute your phone
and hopefully we should be able to hear
you straight away
ah good good evening everybody and
hopefully i've unmuted myself you have
that has done the trick
so thank you very much um i don't know
if you've done this before i think
uh we have three minutes for you to
speak um we will give you a 30-second
warning just before uh your time is up
um and if you could hang around
afterwards uh or uh just for a short
time uh after you finished your speech
um we may have some questions for you
we'll decide
sorry for that whenever you're ready
please do feel free to
um the parish council has previously
supported
uh the previous scheme that was
subsequently refused and
the parish council believes that
the new application has addressed the
three major points identified by the
conservation officer
for the previous schemes grounds for
refusal
these are namely the roof is one meter
lower than before
and so therefore for further more
subservient to the main house
the building is no longer connected to
the house and so there is no
interference for the historic nature and
timelines of the house as it currently
stands
the building is not against the wall
garden as a result
the parish council supports the revised
scheme
and believes it addresses the main
points for the previous refusal and thus
supports
this new application so
in essence that that is what we would
like to
the the committee to listen to and
address happy to take
questions if there are any lovely thank
you very much council jones
members do we have any questions the
pressure council
i'm seeing very little activity there's
a lot of shaking heads now so
uh council jones um i think you're free
to go uh thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you're
you're probably best served watching the
remainder of the uh the meetings through
the
uh the online portal through the live
broadcast um
as thank you very much for your
contribution no problem at all thank you
very much
thank you good evening good evening uh
okay we'll move to our next speaker who
is the agent for the application that is
mr andrew
piwell mr firewall are you there you
will again these press star on sixth one
mute your phone
hello hello we can hear you loud and
clear
um so hopefully you'll have you'll know
now it's three minutes with a 30 second
warning
whenever you're ready please do begin
okay thank you chair i make this
statement on behalf of the applicant and
welcome the opportunity to set out
the key issues that members should take
into account when reaching their
decision
members may recall that i recently
copied them into a letter to the case
officer
pointing out that the objections raised
by the conservation officer were
unfounded
whilst i note that some of the issues
raised do not now feature within the
committee report
the objections that remain still don't
lose still do not stand up to scrutiny
firstly the proposed building is
criticized for having the appearance of
an agricultural outbuilding that would
be more in keeping with an agricultural
setting
however policy cs9 requires proposals to
reflect the character and
distinctiveness of the locality
and states that local context is key to
achieving good design
therefore when taking into account the
site's context as a form of farmstead
the proposals are clearly in accordance
with policy requirements
and do contribute positively to
appreciation of its form of
its significance as a former farmhouse
secondly
contrary to the officer's assertions the
proposed building has been carefully
cited to avoid harm to the character and
distinctiveness of the farmhouse
the site's former use as an orchard or
kitchen garden was purely functional and
not domestic in character
and the fact remains that it lies as far
away from the farmhouse as possible
and out of view from the main habitable
rooms furthermore
since the proposal is single story and
scale and also screen to view by for
substantive vegetation
it stands to reason that it would not
represent a dominant addition to the
site
and thereby simply cannot detract from
the setting of the listed building
or compromise the ability within which
to appreciate its significance
thirdly the officer's report claims that
the proposals would conflict with the
root protection area of the adjacent
trees
but presents no supporting evidence the
applicants are as committed as officers
to ensuring the ongoing health of the
existing tree screen
and if necessary this can always be
achieved through the use of
pile foundations and other standard tree
protection measures
which can be conditioned as necessary
furthermore a landscape condition can
also be imposed to a secure additional
planting
should this be considered appropriate
finally with regard to officers concerns
over climate change and sustainable
construction
i can confirm that the pool room will be
heated with an air source heat pump
which are very efficient in addition to
which there is an opportunity to place
pv panels on the south facing roof
further energy efficiency efficiencies
will be achieved through use of high
performance glazing
argan filled or similar and pir
insulation
and automatic insulated pool cover the
energy consumption will therefore be at
an absolute minimum achieved through
good design and the application of
modern technology
all of which could be secured by
conditions the building itself is an
oak framed for from sustainable source
and will be
employment for skilled uk jobs which is
of an even greater importance in the
current climate
in conclusion it is clear that the
objections raised by officers are
unfounded and as evidenced by the
photographs provided within my recent
letter to the case officer
a more objective site assessment would
have established that the proposals
represent
a balanced and carefully designed scheme
which satisfies all relevant planning
policy requirements
accordingly i would urge members to
reject the officer's recommendation
and grant approval thank you
thank you very much mr barwell uh we do
have a question for you from councillor
parry council perry whenever you're
ready
thank you good evening mr pal um i note
in the report
that the on the dimensions of the pool
house
that it's 17 meters long
i was just interested to know how large
the pool
is the building the building is 17
meters yes
it will either be um 10 or 12 meters
long i i believe
but i would need to clarify that
okay no that's fine
okay uh members do we have any other
questions for the application
the applicant's agent also shaking heads
again
no in that case uh miss powell thank you
so much for your contribution this
evening
uh you again would be better watching
the the remainder of the debate and
discussion uh
through the live broadcast on our
website indeed okay thank you
thank you very much okay um i would move
to the water
member but that is me and i am here
taking part so
i will move straight to uh clarification
uh of points to the officer do we have
any points of clarification
no cro uh councillor jennings
please do dive in
thank you chairman i just wanted to find
out permitted developments
um for sporting and leisure activities
do they come into play here at all
uh because the property is listed
they wouldn't come into here so no and
because
basically because of the listing is a as
a grade two listed building
it would require planning permission in
those cases that's right
thank you very much good question um
councillor parry you have a question
yeah um
eddie i wonder you can just give a bit
more information
because the conservation officer
um advised that it was
that the built the building looked was
out of character because it was more
like an agricultural building um
kind of just have a bit more explanation
on that
um and could we just see a design of the
because we
just have a look at the design of the
pool house itself again
yeah i can get that up and i'll get open
these yeah
yes
uh you should be able to see the um
proposed elevations uh roof plan and
floor plan
now
is that coming through yeah yeah
uh in terms of let me just see what the
conservation officer
said in more detail um
i mean the paragraph that she's talking
about says the proposal for a detached
structure
is an improvement on the previous scheme
uh which was
i believe it was a an attached pool
house to the main house
uh but due to its large size in fairly
close proximity to the listed building
it would still be a dominant addition to
the garden setting
the design similar appearance to an
agricultural building would also be
inconsistent with the garden character
so i think she's gone down the route
that obviously
it's uh it was formerly a farmstead
obviously i think the character
particularly the garden
changing is changing more into a large
sort of mansion house garden type
setting
so without wanting to put words in her
mouth that's what
i seem to glean from what she's saying
there
okay thanks i might eddie just
contribute one
more part of the conservation officer's
words
uh for members consideration says the
existing
um farmhouse garden is on its south and
west sides which appears to be
consistent with the historic arrangement
of the former fast
farmstead when comparison comparing
first edition os maps
the garden area to the west side may
have been an orchard or kitchen garden
which is supported by the remaining
historic brick boundary wall on its
north side
and the garden continues to evoke this
character
which is complemented by the views out
to the surrounding open countryside to
its south
so i think that those comments um from
the conservation officer will help
members understand
what contribution this area of the
garden makes to the setting
of the listed building
lovely thank you very much for that
david uh we have two more people
registered to speak so
uh councillor mills you have a question
yes thanks mr chairman yes i
i wanted to see the um the drawings
i can see in front of me uh but eddie
it's
is it 30 meters away from the house was
that correct
uh approximately around 30 meters that's
right and
is there i couldn't see on the report is
there a foot
path uh anywhere near that
somebody could see this could anybody
see it
i mean in terms of obviously historic
setting
the actual public views aren't as
important so
it's there's a slight difference between
visual one and obviously the setting of
the listed building which doesn't
necessarily have to have a public
viewpoint but i don't believe i i saw
any reference
to long views you know
okay yeah that's it stated there's no
footpath so in terms of landscape
issues and we're not raising any issues
in terms of that or
neighbor impact it's purely the setting
on the list building
okay thank you very much and our final
question is from councillor fleming
council blaming whenever you're ready
yes thank you chairman um just
i don't know if this is actually
relevant at this particular stage but
if we were of a mind to grant this would
we be able to condition that it never
becomes a dwelling either
for a member of the family or whatever
or become a holiday let
that it always was to remain a pool
house
i mean you can associate keep it
associated with the main dwelling
through condition
uh obviously a number of those elements
that you're talking about would require
further
planning permission and so they would
have to apply and they couldn't do it by
stealth as it as it were i mean but we
can attach
certain conditions that it should remain
um ancillary use to the main house
um i don't know if david wants to pick
up on any points but that would be my
understanding yeah i'd agree with what
you said there
eddie certainly we um on on buildings
such as this we have in the past imposed
conditions which
ensure that they remain ancillary to the
main dwelling
it would remain open to any future
owner to apply to have those conditions
removed or to
apply to have the use of the building
changed
and any such application would be dealt
with on its own merits according to the
development plan at the time
okay thank you we have another question
from councillor parry council parry when
you're ready
thank you thank you chairman i just
wonder whether the officers i mean
the the the the
the map in the top right hand corner um
i don't know whether this is to scale
but it would appear that the
proposed um pool house
looks as though its ground area is as
big
as the main house in terms of its
footprint
can the officer advise on that at all
um certainly if you bear with me i can
um
see if i can measure it up
[Music]
um
so the pool house is around 165.5
square meters
this will only be quite approximate but
yeah
[Music]
um
[Music]
so yeah the footprint of the house is
probably about
220 ish
so it's about 25 bigger
footprint approximately yeah it's
obviously a taller building it's um
no i know but i'm just talking about the
actual footage yeah
purely footprint approximately around
the pool house is 75
it's three quarters the footprint 75
percent
around that yeah around of the main
dwelling
thank you yeah i mean and he's probably
best to visually sort of compare i think
on the
probably the actual sizes but yeah you
can see it's
approximately around that 75 footprint
size
okay that appears to be all our
questions and points for clarification
so let's move into the debate
who would like to start
councillor eddon over to you
thank you mr chairman um i think for me
the
conservation officers summed it all up
um and put together quite a strong case
for refusal so
i mean from my point of view i'm very
much minded to go with the officer's
recommendation and we'll actually
propose that
okay very good thank you very much um we
have uh
councillor dixon he's indicating he
wants to start i assume that means speak
but feel free to go thank you chairman
yes i was quite happy to start neil uh
put me to the post
i must admit i take the exact opposite
view i think the conservation officer
has assessed uh the building as not
being
appropriate to a farm house but to an
urban
location uh this isn't an urban location
it's close to a listed farmhouse
and as the report indicates there are no
due to the location there are no public
views of this proposed building
they're citing it as far away from the
listed building and therefore there is
no impact to my mind
on that listing of that building and
therefore
i would be inclined without a doubt to
actually approve
this particular application thank you
and i would propose
i would propose accordingly chairman
what's up man thank you very much uh
councillor parry
thank you thank you chair um well first
of all i actually i
i like the design of the building the
issue i have got
is its scale and size um
and that's the big issue i've got with
it i i think the design
is fine i think the design accords
and for me it's just
a little bit too big um
in terms of scale and uh my view would
be
that if this was if if this was in front
of me
you know and it was sort of like more
more like 50 percent of what the
the main house would be i wouldn't have
have a problem
but it is a huge building
um and and that's where i've more got
the
got the problems problems with so um
but i'll wait to see what everybody else
says
okay lovely lovely thank you councillor
perry council jennings
uh and councillor parry just
uh beat me to it as well and i was
pretty i've got the same sentiments as
her i mean
i read uh visually i don't see it being
a problem at all
the size of it compared to the main
house
it is substantial i mean it is very big
um so i'm sort of sitting on the fence a
bit at the moment
and i will say i'm quite happy to hear
other people's views at the moment
thank you council jennings council mills
gosh we said chairman uh and max have
said
both what i was going to say i you know
originally i thought oh no one can see
this it's away from the um
from the main house you can't be seen
from
footpaths then kazan through googly in
about the size of it she's quite right
so my word i'm in a quandary here mr
chairman um
i'm not sure which way i'm going to go
at the moment so again i like that i'll
uh
listen to other people i've got to say
thank you
thank you councillor mills council
hunter seraphin ah yes
um yeah i'll i'll agree that the size is
too big uh i agree with the conservation
officer
and if you look at it that's a lot of
timber in that building
so now i'd rather i've
second uh neil eden's proposal of uh
go with the officers lovely thank you
very much
councillor kendall thank you thank you
chairman um
i think we're moving in a particular
direction aren't we i mean i
as councillor parry said earlier i don't
object to the principle of the building
being there
i object to the size i think it's
overbearing so
if there was another proposal it came
for another application i should say
that came forward in the future
in that location that was smaller that
would be a different perhaps at this
however i'm going to have to go with the
officer's recommendation
lovely thank you councillor kendall does
anyone else want to have anything to say
at this point
no i will chuck in my two pennies worth
um i think councillor kendall actually
summed it up and obviously canceled
perry as well
um if we weren't looking at a listed
building
i don't think we'd be having a debate
discussion that we are because it's a
listed building i think that's driving
the debate
uh in the direction that it is um it's
it is worth noting
that there are two certainly uh
two it might even be more um reasons for
a refusal
uh within the officer's report um
specifically about
um a lack of information accompanying
the application are
in terms of trees and the impacts it's
having on the trees but also
um and probably more important
certainly of equal importance if not um
more spoken about um recently uh reason
number four which
uh surrounds the climate change spd and
a lack again of information uh
pertaining to that even if we could
overcome
the size and the impact of the uh
of the proposal on the listed building
those two items
would still be outstanding and i'd be
uncomfortable
um whilst you know notwithstanding the
fact that the principle of the idea i
have no issue with
but i'll be uncomfortable um uh granting
an application
where those two bits of frankly vital
information are
are missing um so that's why i've come
to the conclusion i've i
as i say i have no particular issue with
the uh the principle
um size-wise is
is a balance it's a it's you know it's
just an individual
uh decision really there but those are
the two points i think
we it's it's impossible to overcome
those without the information that we
need
um so we have a proposal
we haven't seconded the first proposal
was to refuse and that was from
council edin uh that has been seconded
um i will start
our uh process of voting and i will
um i will say council richards
and that just to be clear that is for
the refusal
so for the refusal thank you chairman
councillor fleming councillor fleming
for
councillor kendall council candle for
councillor crump that's the crown for
thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon councillor dixon
against
sorry think about it that's okay thank
you councillor eden
councillor jennings
councillor journeys for councillor mills
council mills for and councillor parry
councillor parry four that's nine
for chairman and one against marvel
thank you very much liz
so uh committee therefore resolves to a
refuse application twenty zero one
six zero zero ful uh samban farm and
hampton lucy
in line with the officers report
uh members there being no urgent
business
i can happily declare the meeting now
closed
thank you very much for everyone's input
and contributions